this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
thanks for joining us here at 6 30 on
good day las vegas and we are following
a lot of different breaking news
situations including a fire that's
happening right now yeah this is on
mount charleston we've been following
this for a little while now we have
pictures from the scene and some video
as well essentially this is the mount
charleston lodge this is video of it my
goodness that place has been there since
what 1955 56 or something like that and
we've heard from folks up on the
mountain from clark county fire the
mount charleston lodge fully engulfed in
this morning has essentially burned down
yeah you can see those flames are pretty
awful so of course the roads in the area
are closed and we're working to find out
if everyone was able to get out safely
hearing some stories about getting you
know the knock on the door saying get
out get out now so we are following that
i spoke with the one of the members of
the town advisory board up there and she
says that she has not heard any reports
of injuries we'll wait to get that
confirmed from clark county fire but
very serious that's an historic building
up there everybody knows the mount
charleston lodge so we have a crew on
the way up there right now but again the
mount charleston lodge has essentially
burned to the ground this morning we'll
get the latest for you as soon as we can
that's a tough one other breaking news
going on this morning a major traffic
problem a deadly traffic wreck this
morning nate you can tell us a little
bit more about what's happening there
man so much going on john and heather
and sherry and i talking about the
iconic nature of the lodge up there but
let's get to this fatal crash happened
earlier this morning at the intersection
of spring mountain and decatur